in Ratingen bei Düsseldorf hat es am
Morgen in einem Hochhaus eine Explosion
gegeben dabei sind nach vorläufigen
Erkenntnissen Sinn Feuerwehrleute und
zwei Polizeibeamte zum Teil schwer
verletzt worden gegen 10 Uhr morgens
haben die wohnungseigentümergesellschaft
die Polizei verständigt dass ein
Briefkasten eines Bewohners überquelle
sagte Nordrhein-Westfalens Innenminister
Herbert Reul im Düsseldorfer Landtag die
Polizei habe vor Ort die Feuerwehr
hinzugezogen um die Tür zu öffnen dann
kam es offensichtlich zu einer
Detonation der Lothar Becker ist vor Ort
in Ratingen Lothar was ist bislang
bekannt
im Moment scheint hier der Zugriff der
spezial-einsatzkräfte zu laufen die
sollen in die Wohnung und wie es
momentan offiziell von der Polizei heißt
herausfinden was dort im Moment los ist
es könnte also sein dass dort a noch
eine Person drin ist die verletzt ist es
könnte aber auch sein dass da noch eine
Person drin ist von der möglicherweise
eine Gefahr ausgeht und deswegen wurden
also Spezial Einsatzkräfte hinzugezogen
der ganze Bereich hier weiträumig
abgesperrt auch wir Journalisten dürfen
nicht mehr heran es handelt sich hier um
dieses weiße Gebäude hinter mir die
Rückseite dort gibt es auch einen Balkon
der auf einen Hinterhof hinaus ragt und
von dort aus könnte natürlich wenn eine
gefährliche Person dort noch in der
Wohnung sein sollte auch eine Gefahr für
Menschen bestehen ansonsten ist ja noch
im Moment unklar wie das ganze Prozedere
jetzt weiter läuft wie gesagt die
knallenden Geräusche die wir in den
letzten Momenten gehört haben und
Minuten sind von dem Zugriff der in
diesen Minuten erfolgt
vielen Dank für diese ersten
Erkenntnisse
[Musik]